Congressman chip Roy of Texas kind
enough to join us right now Congressman
um a lot hangs in the balance in that
meeting and I do want to get to politics
in New Hampshire and your fance for
Rhonda sandis but this meeting and
whether it will help avoid a shutdown
what do you
think well first of all let me be very
clear clear bill baluan has done great
reporting and I really appreciate you
all clarifying that that was 100% not
true with all due respect to my
colleague Henry qu it's just not true uh
that it was because Texas governor's
office has been trying to establish
their strength there in that particular
spot in Eagle Pass that somehow that
blocked out border patrol from getting
to those migrants we had a thousand
migrants die along the border last year
Neil we had 53 who got a cooked in a
tractor trailer in San Antonio and
listening to Democrats try to blame us
in Texas for what's happening to
migrants it's absolutely appalling
what's happening right now this
conversation we need to secure the
border of the United States absolutely
first before we even have a conversation
about funding for Ukraine and I hope
Mike Johnson will stick to his guns on
on that I've disagreed with him on the
spending front I think we need to cut
spending but he's been pretty strong on
this but he better stay strong because
this is a non-negotiable position for
the house conference in my opinion well
you've been very clear on that
congressman and and some of your
colleagues are are being even clear that
uh they fear that he will cave he'll
make you know allowances for the other
side uh and they might want his head
what do you think of
that well look Mike has been pretty
strong about saying when to secure the
border before we even have a
conversation about Ukraine so I'm going
to trust them to continue to do that but
there's going to be an accountability on
this uh we don't like what we're doing
with the CRS we don't like the spending
levels we don't like what happened with
the ndaa it's not been the right
direction uh I know it's a thin majority
but what we're dealing with in Texas
governor Abbott is 100% right to be
aggressive we've spent 12 a half billion
dollars our state is under siege we're
the ones taking it on the chin and then
to watch these guys get all twisted
knots like Martha Vineyard when they got
a plane load of 50 when they were sent
there by Governor Ronda santis to shake
things up or or New York or Chicago
Mayors complaining about getting a few
thousands sent to their cities we have
millions pouring across Texas so I'm
look I'm all on board Governor RIT can
be as aggressive as he wants and he'll
have my full support So a couple of your
colleagues with them I was chatting and
many on Fox Business Congressman which
if you don't get you should demand
fortunately you're on Fox Business
enough you know it already and you
demand it and got it and that's the way
it is having said that though
Congressman one of the things I first
heard from many of them is that no no no
if it's a choice between shutting the
government down and just taking a pass
on the border again it isn't going to
work shut the government down do you
agree with
that look I will tell you this I'm on
the phone constantly with Ranchers with
law enforcement sheriffs in South Texas
right before uh uh speaker Johnson took
folks down to the Border I called them
and I said guys what are you doing
because I wasn't going to make that trip
and they said you've got and they told
speaker Johnson the same thing you have
got to shut the border down or shut the
government down they get it they
understand understand that it's it's tax
money that we take and borrowed money to
fund a government that is at odds with
the people of Texas I mean nobody's
jonesing for a government shutdown but
we're really sick and tired of funding
the very bureaucracy that's undermining
our freedom we are not following the
Constitution we are not providing the
the service the federal government is
supposed to provide to secure the border
of the United States so we're going to
stick to our guns on this and I I fully
backed Texas taking whatever uh efforts
we need to do it if the federal
government won't and fully of Governor
abbit doing that he can be as aggressive
as he wants to be like I said
Congressman You' have been a early and a
strong supporter uh you know even
getting the wrath of Donald Trump and a
lot of his backers of Ronda sis uh he's
not pulling well in New Hampshire he
seems to be putting his focus elsewhere
he he's looking like he's in a world of
political hurt do you think you're
hooked up with the wrong
horse absolutely not uh you never uh
regret saddling up with someone who is a
good human being a good man a good
husband a good father someone with a
track record of what he's accomplished
in Florida this nation would be so
blessed to have Ronda sandis in the
white house I'm gonna ride along with
him as long as he wants to go and I
think he's got a message that's
resonating we're in New Hampshire right
now everybody say oh he's taking out
he's going to South Carolina I'm talking
to you from a hotel in Manchester we
just had an event that was filled with a
bunch of people who love the message
that Governor de santis is delivering
look we're realists I can look at
numbers uh but look let's also peel back
what happened in Iowa president Trump
the incumbent if you will only got half
the vote of a very depressed turnout of
110,000 of the people who showed up
7,000 were Democrats and almost all of
those went to Nikki Haley Nikki Haley's
support in New Hampshire is pretty much
fake it is a mix of Independence soft RS
the support in Iowa was Democrats
pumping her up she dumped 26 million
against uh Governor de santis only to
come in third I mean talking about not
having a date for the prompt she's
coming to New Hampshire she's going to
lose if she goes to South Carolina she's
going to lose she's playing for I don't
even know what meanwhile she's taking
away from the American people currently
the ability of having a head-to-head
race between two heavyweights Governor
Dan santis who's delivered for the
people of Florida and former president
Trump I think with that choice
head-to-head we'd have a real debate and
you know what maybe president Trump
would actually show up to a debate Niki
Haley's not showing up to debates
president Trump has showed up to no
debates so govern she is I know are just
polls Congressman I apologize for that
but but she is swamping him right now in
New Hampshire that might change uh I
would imagine she has a better chance of
doing better than him at least in South
Carolina you're quite right right now
that could be Donald Trump's to lose but
she's not doing too
poorly well again she spent $26 million
and use 7,000 Democrats to come in third
in Iowa she is going to try to
monopolize the more moderate flank of
the voters in New Hampshire and she's
still going to lose she's going to go to
mely in Iowa from the very beginning
being among the earliest candidates and
like you say he did come in second but
he didn't win one single County in
Iowa well he worked it really hard and
got 21% of the vote despite the fact
polls said he was going to be at 13 or
14 and he did it because he did do all
that hard work and let's be very clear
with all due respect to Fox and I like
I'm I'm happy to be on with you but the
earned media advantage president Trump
it's like 20 to1 and you go look at the
spread in the chart since last March
after the brag indictments the massive
amount of news that has been going on
since last March that earn media
Advantage is really difficult to go up
against and so look Governor D santis
did the hard work out in Iowa and that's
how he earned that 21% that second place
finish so we'll see what happens going
forward but look we're in New Hampshire
he's going to be in New Hampshire in
South Carolina this weekend and he's
working it hard all right well if I'm an
earned media Advantage boy that's a that
would ADV manage change for me uh it's
always good having you on Congressman
thank you very much for taking the time
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else